jetzt ist dachte ich ich habe schon
lange keinen fernseher mehr geschaut ich
mach mir mal einen gemütlichen
fernsehabend bis plötzlich eine
zahnpasta die komplett auf lou reed
verzichten kann
prüfen sie ob ihre ich habe mich
beruhigt ich habe mir einen tee gemacht
damit wir in aller ruhe über florida und
zahnpasta sprechen können es gibt
verschiedene fluorid freie zahnpasten
auf dem markt das ist erstmal nichts
neues aber als ich beim fernsehschauen
über diese werbung stolperte die story
bevor wir starten nur damit es keine
missverständnisse gibt flur und fluorid
sind nicht dasselbe flur ist sehr giftig
war sehr reaktiv florid ist richtung
reaktiv stichwort oktett hrige und so
weiter machen wir weiter für die
umstrittene chemikalie fluorid in
zahnpasten strenge grenzwerte definiert
deutsche wissenschaftler haben jetzt
entwickelt eine zahnpasta die komplett
auf logik verzichten nur weil die
grenzwerte für florieren zahnpasten
wurden bereits 1978 festgelegt und haben
sich seither auch nicht geändert das ist
keine reaktion auf irgendwelche neuen eu
grenzwerte seite natürlich die reaktion
kommt 40 jahre zu spät
prüfen sie ob ihre zum bauen wenn ihr
schon arbeitet dann prüft auch bitte ob
eure zahnpasta älter als 40 jahre ist so
damit das klar ist jede zahnpasta die
ihr in der eu kauft überschreitet keine
fluorid grenzwerte jetzt auf lou reed
verzichten ohne florida gegen karies
okay schauen wir uns doch erst mal an
wie karies genau entsteht erst mal aus
was besteht eigentlich so ein zahn der
großteil des zahnschmelzes besteht aus
einem mineral namens hydroxylapatit es
ist eine unreine form des hydroxylapatit
das heißt nicht dass sie zähne schmutzig
sind sondern chemisch gesehen unrein es
ist kein reines hydroxylapatit um das zu
verstehen ganz kurz was ist eigentlich
genau so ein mineral ein mineral ist ein
salz oder eine juden verbindung genauso
wie natriumchlorid unser kochsalz oder
kalziumkarbonat unser kalk in der küche
auch hydroxylapatit besteht aus
verschiedenen johnen nämlich aus
kalziumphosphat und foxi tionen die
gemeinsam ein kristallgitter bilden in
unseren seelen sind aber auch manchmal
andere johnen zu gast im kristallgitter
zum beispiel karbonat oder flo regionen
dh selbst in einem festen material wie
unseren zähnen selbst in einem festen
kristallgitter können sich einzelne
ionenaustausch lange rede gut zu sehen
unsere zähne sind ein mineral das aus
ionen besteht sowie entsteht jetzt
karies unsere zähne sind von einem
biofilm umgehend genannt klack in der
plug hausen viele kleine mikroorganismen
diese mikroorganismen freuen sich wenn
wir kohlenhydrate und vor allem zucker
essen weil sie das dann in säure
umwandeln säure heißt der ph-wert in
unserem und sinkt was bedeutet jetzt ein
sinkender ph wert für unser zahn mineral
das ist ganz ähnlich wie bei dem kalk in
unserer küche kalt also kalziumkarbonat
ist ja deswegen so nervig weil es so
schlecht in wasserlöslich ist es sei
denn wir haben einen tiefen also sauren
ph nw dem kalk mit essig oder
irgendeinem anderen sauren kalk entferne
auf die pelle rücken
dann löste sich auf genau das passiert
auch mit unseren zielen was dann auch zu
den löchern führt voila karies paris
heißt unsere zähne lösen sich auf man
sagt dazu auch die mineralisation wie
kann man career sitzt also bekämpfen
mitre mineralisation okay wie geht das
kommen wir noch mal zurück zu unseren
unreinen hydroxylapatit oft ist es so je
eine ein kristallgitter ist desto
stabiler ist die kristall struktur und
desto schwerer ist es aufzulösen genau
das auflösen wollen wir verhindern die
fremden ionen die sich im kristallgitter
austauschen stören das kristallgitter
normalerweise mit einer ausnahme und
zwar fluorid das fluorid ion ist nämlich
sehr klein
wenn es sich anstelle eines hypoxi die
uns in das kristallgitter einsetzt
entsteht dadurch ein dichteres und
stabileres kristallgitter in anwesenheit
von bereits wenigen flur ionen kann sich
flora petit oder flur hydroxylapatit
bilden was viel stabiler ist als
hydroxylapatit das bleibt beständig bei
sauren ph
das löst sich auf kein loch loch so
lange also chlorid ionen im speichel
oder in der kerb vorhanden sind können
sie sich in die apatit struktur hinein
bauen und so die auflösung verlangsamen
oder sogar verhindern
die mineralisation nennt man dass der
zahn kann sich wieder aufbauen na schön
aber es gibt doch bestimmt eine
alternative zu florieren nehmen wir doch
mal als beispiel das produkt aus der
werbung hier wird statt florida
hydroxylapatit eingesetzt also dass
zahnmaterial zähneputzen mit zahnschmelz
quasi ging doch erstmal einleuchtende
wenn carius durch die auflösung von
zahlen steht fügen wir einfach mehr
zahlen hinzu um so die idee
mineralisation aufzuhalten wo werden wir
uns diese grafik anschauen erscheint das
ganze weniger sinnvoll bei tiefen ph
also ab einem ph von fünf löst sich die
druck sie aktiv schnell auf was bringt
es also über die zahnpasta noch mehr
hydroxylapatit hinzuzufügen wenn es sich
doch sowieso auflöst wenn wir in szene
aber mit fluorid putzen entsteht flur
apatit was deutlich weniger löslich ist
kein loch aber das ist ja auch nur meine
theorie nach rein logisch chemischem
verständnis vielleicht zeigt die praxis
ja was ganz anderes schauen wir doch mal
auf der homepage des herstellers was
sagen die medien sagen die medien
wen interessiert schon was
wissenschaftler und mehr zu sagen ich
möchte wissen was galileo dazu sagt wird
ein experte gegenüber gestellt
irgendso einem random schauspieler gut
in der bar und am ende weiß man halt
nicht wie man jetzt von beiden glauben
so in professor vom bundesinstitut für
risikobewertung oder irgendeinem blut in
der bar schwierig schwierig schauen wir
doch mal lieber was die moderne
wissenschaft sagt die wissenschaft sagt
fluri der helfen gegen karies dass es
gut untersucht und es ist nicht
umstritten und das sage nicht ich das
habe ich aus einer quelle die der
hersteller selbst auf seiner seite
verlinkt attacke aber schauen wir doch
mal was ihr sonst noch so verlinkt ist
hier wird auf eine studie verwiesen wo
kindern 30 tage lang einmal zahnpasta
mit und einer ohne hydroxylapatit
gegeben wurde diese zahnpasten waren
aber nicht florid frei deswegen sagt
diese studie überhaupt nichts darüber
aus ob hydroxylapatit ohrid ersetzen
könnte oder nicht sei aber auch blöd
wenn jemand wirklich in die studien
reinschaut jemand allerdings kann aber
auch wirklich keiner rechnen übrigens
ich möchte nicht leugnen dass
hydroxylapatit nicht untersucht wurde
oder wird und das ist womöglich positive
wirkungen haben kann in der zahnpflege
allgemein nur gegen karies schützt es
nicht ausgerechnet der punkt der ist
nicht nachgewiesen
und nochwas freue mich gerne ein es gibt
natürlich andere kariesprophylaxe außer
floride aber wenn floride doch so super
wirken warum sollte man darauf
verzichten weil sie giftig sind kann man
prinzipiell zu viel florida haben ja so
wie bei fast allen stoffen gibt es
grenzwerte die nicht überschritten
werden sollten wenn ihr studien findet
die sich mit toxizität und florin
beschäftigen dann schaut bitte auf zwei
sachen nämlich erstens die konzentration
und zweitens die art und weise der
exposure also lokal beim zähneputzen
oder durch essen und trinken die
wahrscheinlich toxische dosis für einen
menschen liegt bei 5 milligramm fluorid
pro kilogramm körpergewicht übrigens pro
babbel um sicherzugehen die certain die
toxic das liegt höher
es wird gefährlich wenn kleinkinder
die wenig wie in größere mengen an
zahnpasta essen deswegen empfehlen
zahnärzte kinder zahnpasta dieses
prioritär mal weil man eben nicht immer
verhindern kann dass das kind die
zahnpasta schluckt wenn man zu viel
fluorid zu sich nimmt zum beispiel durch
trinkwasser oder durch die nahrung diese
gefahr besteht hier in deutschland nicht
kann man eine flow rose airline eine
frau rose kamera aber nicht allein wenn
man sich ganz normal die zähne putzt
oder die zahnpasta zu essen weil der
fluoridgehalt in zahnpasten auch beim
wir zahnes aber unbedenklich das limit
begrenzt wurde
und es ist eure entscheidungen sind auch
eure zähne ihr könnt euch die zähne
putzen wie ihr möchtet ich will nur dass
ihr bescheid wisst und das tut er jetzt
wo ihr das video bis hierhin gesehen
habt und damit ist meine arbeit hier
erledigt
leipzig